this season is going to be bigger and
better than you have ever experienced so
get ready bigger and better but now the
reel has been canceled
welcome to the real america we have a
fantastic show planned for you today e.t
can confirm the news that the daytime
panel show hosted by lonnie love genie
mai garcelle bouvet and adrian houghton
is ending after eight seasons on the air
lonnie is not a morning
person all
genie has more energy for everybody and
adrian couldn't be sweeter i'm the
bitter divorcee on friday lonnie opened
up about the news on instagram writing
in the end the real cast and crew did
everything we could to scale the show
down we shot seven to eight shows in
three days no audience made a conference
room into a studio but in my opinion
covid costs killed this show the 50 year
old comedian added that it's been a
great ride before thanking viewers and
shouting out their emmy win writing this
is not goodbye but see you all soon
our man right there
e.t was with the ladies of the real back
in 2018 after they took home emmy gold
for outstanding talk show entertainment
i i'm still in shock and you just i
don't know we're always the show that
feels like we're just working hard to
prove ourselves so tonight was a minute
where like god just took all control we
literally got off the stage turned the
corner and huddled in a prayer and we
were just like thank you god and so
we're so grateful and we will never ever
forget this moment in the way we feel
right now we work so hard people don't
realize how hard it is and i'm thinking
about it getting emotional because
all we wanted to do was be given a
chance
and people believed in us and we call
ourselves the little show that couldn't
and we did
rumors at the show was facing
cancellation started swirling back in
march
at the time lonnie addressed the gossip
on twitter writing quote it's been a
busy few days but i got a call from the
studio no official decision has been
made about the real and she made one
request of the folks at home i will be
okay but please give grace to the 150
crew members this may affect we will
finish season 8 and wait for official
word
when the reel premiered in 2013 it
started as a panel of five co-hosts
including tamara mowry taymar braxton
jeannie adrian and lonnie tamar and
tamara eventually parted ways with the
show i love visiting
and i promise the girls that you know i
i will i just you know told my producer
that i will you know i will be there
when when the time a lot i feel like i'm
definitely going to be visiting whenever
i can and garcelle joined the panel in
2020
i've uh
became a host of the real a co-host of
the real i mean that's amazing i tested
with a bunch of you know different women
and who all were capable of doing the
job but i'm thrilled that i was the
chosen one the girls and i are just
seamless that's seamless that's
effortless it's a lot of fun i think we
have a really great group
and i'm beyond excited about it
[Music]